is the Democratic primary rigged the way
it works is so outrageous we need to
sugarcoat it for you each state has
delegates up for grabs in the primaries
people vote and the delegates are
divided up proportionally the candidate
wins the nomination if they get the most
delegates so let's take New Hampshire as
an example Bernie got sixty percent of
the vote there so he got 15 delegates
Hillary got nine so Bernie one right
well not quiet because here's the catch
every state also has extra delegates
called super delegates they are party
insiders and elected leaders who can
pick whichever candidate they want they
make sure the nominee is an off message
and will advance the party's entry six
of the New Hampshire super-delegates
said they plan to support Hillary so as
of now Bernie and Hillary are even in
that state frustrated yet well this
could happen again nationally Hillary
has a huge super delegate lead but these
super delegates can change their minds
back in 2008 many pledged to Hillary
then switch to Barack Obama when it
became clear the voters were leaning
that way so far these high-powered
decision makers have never swung any
national election but when Hillary super
super delegate lead could 2016 be the
first year that happens
you